einige dieser neuen sozusagen hass wird
haben wir gerade schon gehört neben home
office vor allen dingen homeschooling
darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen auch
mit dem arche gründer hier aus berlin
bernd siggelkow schönen guten abend herr
siggelkow den homeschooling ja das ist
für uns alle wahnsinnig anstrengend und
wenn man ehrlich ist bedeutet distanz
unterricht allzu oft kein unterricht
aber wie ist das erst für arme familien
kinderreiche familien beschreiben sie
uns herr siggelkow mal die aktuelle
situation in berlin wie das da überhaupt
noch gehupt wird aktuell das ganze
homeschooling also die kinder sind schon
ein bisschen an ihre grenzen gekommen
das große problem ist natürlich dass bei
vielen die das equipment fehlt das heißt
also manche abend kein laptop dann
fehlen natürlich die druckerpatronen
dafür ist kein geld da kein papier
die nerven liegen noch ein bisschen lang
weil man gar keinen ausweg mehr sieht
was wo ist das licht am ende des tunnels
die eltern sind völlig überfordert weil
die sind ja auch keine lehrer die sind
entsprechend nicht ausgebildet haben
viele kinder dann ist man auf engstem
raum zusammen und da sind probleme
natürlich vorprogrammiert
aber das bedeutet ja ich die spanne wird
noch größer also reich gut gebildeter
akademiker familien so im schnitt
zumindest können das ganz gut meistern
einigermaßen die kinder gehen da
möglicherweise noch mit vorteilen aus
dieser krise raus und ja bei armen
familien bei kinderreichen familien dort
findet möglicherweise kann gar keine
bildung stattfinden zu hause und die
kluft wird noch größer im moment ja das
hatte ich ja schon im ersten lok tor und
gesagt dass die gefahr natürlich sehr
groß ist dass die abgehängten kinder
jetzt noch abgehängt sind
das ist ja die große herausforderung
diese kinder gern zu hause nicht so
gefördert wie kinder aus einem guten
bildungsschicht oder wo die eltern
vielleicht ja auch noch fitter sind
natürlich ist das große problem dass es
in diesen familien viele defizite gibt
viele probleme und jedes weitere problem
was dazu kommt sei es dass das geld
nicht unbedingt da es um alles zu
gewährleisten denn die kinder haben ja
vorher auch in der schule gegessen in
berlin kostenlos das heißt dass feldweg
das heißt die belastung für die eltern
ist größer auch in den arm nahm die
kinder gegessen und da kann natürlich
ganz schnell so eine kleinigkeit dazu
führen dass ist ja so eskaliert dass ich
auch oft anrufe
für die überforderten müttern oder auch
von kindern die sagen aber ich habe
immer streiten oder und wir merken es
bei unseren eigenen whatsapp gruppen das
innerhalb von kürzester zeit irgendein
kind auch mal auszieht und man muss den
sehr intervenieren weil es bei uns
natürlich alles moderiert hellwig
genauso wie die politiker eigentlich
ignorieren wir immer kinder die nicht in
familien leben habe ich das gefühl in
der gesellschaft in dem in den medien
auch in der politik aber wie geht es den
kindern wie zb ein kinderheim leben die
in betreuten wohnungseinrichtung leben
über die wird irgendwie nie geredet
gefühlt wie geht es diesen kindern und
vor allem was bedeuten die beschlüsse
für sie das ist natürlich eine große
herausforderung in den kinderheimen weil
da gibt natürlich auch nur für sachen
geld wo man von vornherein ausgegangen
ist ich weiß von vielen einrichtungen da
fehlt es auch an den wesentlichsten da
brauchen wir jetzt nochmal zusätzliche
personen die beim homeschooling helfen
auf der anderen seite auch das
technische equipment zur verfügung
stellen und natürlich diese kontakt
beschränkung für die kinder ab drei
jahre
es ist natürlich ganz schwer zu erklären
ich darf als einzelperson nicht zwei
personen empfangen darf aber zu den zwei
personen ausgehen als erwachsene da kann
ich mir das irgendwie noch ein bisschen
zusammenreißen aber wie soll ich das ein
kind erklären und die geht ein kind
damit um das ist für sie schon
unvorstellbar und die isolation wird
immer größer und die führt dazu dass ein
großes unverständnis auch bei den
kindern erst jetzt hören wir ja seit
monaten vor allen dingen virologen wären
ganz viele politiker sowieso gehören ab
und zu auch ökonom was es mit ihrer
perspektive an der basis von der arche
würden sie aktuell sagen sofort am
besten den locker und beenden weil eben
die sozialen folgen weil die folgen für
die kinder
soja vernichtend sind natürlich wäre es
gut wenn die kinder wieder in die schule
gehen weil sie dort ihre sozialkontakte
haben da gibt es menschen die sie sehen
und auch vielleicht sehen wir wie
problematisch sie jetzt gerade sind wir
haben viele kinder die haben es schon
genommen wir haben den ganzen tag vom pc
und spielen computer die sind schon
süchtig geworden
ich glaube dass man dafür sorgen muss
dass die lehrer mehr kontakt haben zu
ihren schülern das wir haben ganz viele
kinder wo der lehrer sich nicht werde
der gibt ihn einfach 60 blätter mit ihr
sollen sie aus
schön innerhalb von einer woche sollen
sie dann am nächsten montag wieder in
die schule bringen wenn nur jeder lehrer
x 15 minuten am tag ein kind anrufen
würde zumindest alle drei tage um den
kontakt zu halten
die eltern zu unterstützen dann werden
die auch nicht so schnell den kopf in
den sand stecken aber solange das nicht
passiert und brennpunktschulen das
gefühl haben bei ihnen brennt ist noch
mehr
dann wird eskalation vorprogrammiert
sein dann muss man sich nicht wundern
wenn kinder dann wenn die schule wieder
losgeht morgens nicht aus dem bett
kommen weil sie eben eine ganz andere
tagesstruktur haben
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren